hi welcome to I did likes i'm justine
and i have been sick the past couple of
days i felt absolutely terrible i've
been wearing the same shirt i think
since the last video that i shot which
was a couple of days ago so that's just
lets you know how disgusting i feel and
em right now really sexy the good news
though is i have showered i've just
opted to put the same shirt back on like
pig why don't you go find another shirt
i don't know it's just really
comfortable thankfully this week has
been really good to us as far as videos
go cuz i've really been just sitting
around watching youtube videos
and breaking bad holy crap the last
episode of Breaking Bad oh my god I
can't wait for tonight so onto these
YouTube videos that are watching I came
in her house this little kitten oh my
god my heart like melted like the inside
of my heart just melted maybe that's why
I've been sick but it's so cute like
this cat I want to smother it and it to
my bosom people actually say bosom I
don't think they do
oh god this next video a bunch of you
guys sent me this and finally I decided
to click on one of you guys who tweeted
it to me it's what does the Fox say
and the seal goes ow ow ow but Bethel
town no no
basically this music video was created
by these two brothers who were in this
band yellow vus I think I'm pronouncing
it probably completely incorrect they
are brothers they have a talk show in
Norway so they shot this video to
promote their talk show and they had no
idea that it was actually become this
popular and the funniest thing as I read
some article of an interview that they
did with him and they said they did a
screening of this video for like 10
people in their office and not a single
person laughed are you kidding me I was
just like laying in my bed feeling like
complete death and I watch this video
and almost crap to myself so I'm
wondering what do you guys think a fox
sounds like I've actually seen foxes in
my backyard of my parents house because
you live out the middle of nowhere you
tend to see a lot of wild animals what
do they say I'm not sure I think it
probably sounds a little something like
this
[Music]
I came in thank some comments below and
try to depict your Fox sounds in text so
I'll feature a couple of those in the
next episode of ID like next up gaming
and tech I am so excited finally GTA 5
is out and no I am NOT the GTA 5 cover
girl That's not me
although iPhone yeah whatever rocks are
I ain't mad though I'm pretty excited
for the multiplayer so GTA online will
be coming out October 1st and I believe
it's just a free download if you've
already purchased the game so October
1st
you cannot come quick enough so this
game is probably gonna replace all of my
saint's row game play so I'm sorry to
anybody who watches the gaming channel
and enjoys my Saints Row games I'm
moving on you know that's life just just
to get up you gotta go with it
sorry had to turn the fan off speaking
of games i've been playing also on my
gaming channel ducktales remastered and
for those of you guys that are old
enough yeah so remember this this game
was released originally on Nintendo in
1989 which seems like forever ago but I
have memories of being four years old
playing this game and my mom just
getting so mad because she want me to
stop playing my game I'm like mom one
more level one more level please I'm
almost done and so weird not because I
don't have anyone to yell at me to stop
playing video games so kids let me tell
you that is the best part about being an
adult as long as you get your work done
you can do whatever you want this is so
sexy then I'll be your eyes in the
sukkah launchpad I'd be happy if you
just keep your eyes on the sky freak
English I'll still love you oh yeah
next up is a book club let me know what
books you guys have been downloading
this week I'm not really sure what book
I want to download so please let me know
because you guys are so in the know that
it makes my mind just explode if you
guys want to get your free book like
always that's super simple you just go
to audible.com slash iJustine and if you
have an Amazon account you can log in
download your free book let me know
which one you get and that's really
that's really all there is to it
honestly I can't believe that I have
never until the past couple of months
used an audiobook like where have these
been all my life
I can now drive in my car and feel like
I'm being intellectual anyway link is in
description moving right along I want to
chat with you guys about some beauty and
fashion because I'm feeling so
fashionable obviously in this current
state I should be talking about nothing
that has to do with fashion or style but
let me tell you what you can always take
a shower and put the same shirt back on
you could not brush your hair and um
just doesn't matter because you know
what on the Internet
[Music]
do I look really nice right now no I
just feel awful also just realized I've
been wearing the same shirt since
Thursday so I'm doing a beauty and style
segment right now what should I talk
about thank you yeah it actually doesn't
even stink yeah that is true
honestly I want your honest opinion cuz
I don't think it does come here this is
what it smells like
is your stink what but it smells you can
still smell the fabric softener so it's
like a stinky person and plus fabric
softener really yeah and you only smell
the fabrics often because you can't
smell your own stink no yeah that's what
happened guys my fashion tip for you is
to take a shower oh my god I feel like
death ah anyway thank you guys for
watching let me know a book I should get
this week while I'm sitting and trying
to feel better that's all I've got for
you oh yeah that's all I'm gonna go to
sleep I think I love you bye
I mean just dancing in the street things
know a car it's a little top of my car